uh what about personally what plans do  you have for the holidays other than  watching the movie  than anything  um since my divorce because this was  going to be the year that I didn't have  my kids Christmas morning  um but I've never looked forward to a  day  um more now than ever um I now I'm gonna  get my kids on Christmas Day at noon and  Santa it's actually come the next day so  we're gonna celebrate Christmas the next  day so I don't miss out on you know  their little feet Pitter pattering  coming down and and seeing the presents  from Santa so I'm excited to create our  own memory this year and I'm really  looking forward to that oh that's  awesome  I'm so glad that worked out right there  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]